jennar on peut se parler de minutes oui
pourquoi est il y avec nous quelqu'un
que j'aime énormément qui est vraiment
un des garçons qui me fait le plus rire
vous le savez on en parle encore dans la
loge il ya un instant avec avec benjamin
castaldi on a eu des petits qui souciait
dans touche pas à mon poste et c'est sûr
voilà le canular l'année l'an dernier
tout est le premier quelques toiles à
cagnes est bon que c'était une mauvaise
blague mais qui a pris notre défense et
elie semoun revient pour te faire
plaisir après je te faire joli oui oui
j'aimerais qu'on se fasse un truc parce
qu on a un qui tous les deux c'est faire
des coups de fil c'est assez pour ben
oui pardon il est déjà dans le contrat
avec mes parents et mon commissaire
frichards de la dpa saisie je vous
appelle je suis bien au bar la cession
ou la non attends t'es oui oui pardon
choléra
la cac et équité qui fait non mais y'a
pas qui c'est qui fait qu'ils s'aiment
mais je sais c'est pas ta voix bizarre
mais ça c'est que c'est une blague bien
sûr qu'il fait une voix bizarre cette
fois l'ancien le plus normale possible
qu'ils accordent y aussi la chine a
repoussé par les deux minutes oui
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
allô oui le paradis du coach cool alors
oui je crois que oui mais non oui
bonjour madame commissaire profession je
vous appelle parce qu'on a un petit
doute là sur la clientèle vous êtes en
observation la madame madame c'est le
commissaire berck amant dans live boris
c'est toi qui as fini le nutella dakar
avec mango allô allô oui la caravelle
oui oui bonjour désolé nous dire en
léger le commissaire richard
je vous appelle concernant un laser
le diabolo fraise et de transit le
diabolo belle dans tout le
allô allô bonjour madame pardon excusez
moi
là on est un petit peu dans l'excitation
policière vous m'entendez la wii voilà
on a un petit problème nadar
il ya une personnes malfaisantes qui
douanes dans votre restaurant qui c'est
qui doit être actuellement avec une
personne masculine est ce que c'est bien
le cas madame maya du monde exact je
suis d'accord madame oui c'est c'est en
fait c'est elie semoun à l'appareil
oui vous êtes en direct sur ses vitres
[Musique]
de ma mère c'est vraiment nous en bas il
vient de comprendre un accord vous nous
connaissez vous pouvez nous décrire et
laissez-vous de pointe d'écrire elle est
comment vous avez vu à la télé il ya pas
longtemps je l'espère un climat serein
kinder bueno aires
et hanouna où il décrit mois quand vous
décrire ça fait plaisir déjà elle est
belle la france
je n'ai pas de compte mais merci va ça
nous a fait plaisir merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]